[Music]
hi everyone
welcome back today i'm really excited to
tell you about one of my favorite topics
in fluid dynamics specifically
turbulence
and i've been looking forward to this
video for a long time because it's one
of the
kind of most interesting topics in
fluids
that has captivated people for really
for millennia
okay so um great art has been made
to try to capture the nature of
turbulence not just da vinci
we have van gogh and we have the great
wave
turbulence is a part of our literature
it's a part of our very language some of
my favorite words
uh roiling churning uh turbulent these
mean
so much to us and so today what we're
going to talk about specifically
is what is turbulence okay and so you
know even though
we have a very intuitive feeling of what
in turbulent flow
is uh and is not it's actually very hard
to pin down
a single kind of unique definition that
we can all agree on
and so instead of trying to do that i'm
going to bring up some kind of key
features of turbulence
and walk you through some examples of
turbulent flows
how they're useful and how we might
analyze them
as engineers so uh turbulent flows
generally are three-dimensional that's
one of the the hallmark features
of turbulence and in principle
you can technically have approximately
2d flows that exhibit turbulence but
that's like a special case
so for example weather on the surface of
earth
we have a thin atmosphere and so the
fluid dynamics are approximately
two-dimensional
but you get weird things like small
vorticity adds up to make bigger and
bigger
vortices and form hurricanes which you
don't see in kind of a classical
three-dimensional turbulence
so when i say turbulence i really mean
kind of the three-dimensional turbulence
where things are
spinning and roiling in three dimensions
turbulent flows are multi-scale okay so
they're multi-scale
in space and time which means that there
are big eddies and medium eddies and
small eddies
and smaller ones that infinite okay and
you'll notice that all of these features
that i'm going to list are actually in
this davinci painting so this is clearly
kind of his attempt at
three-dimensionality
it is highly multi-scale you can see
kind of self-similar patterns
it's unsteady even though this is a
fixed image it clearly evokes motion
okay so turbulent flows are not fixed
they're not stationary they are evolving
in time
they are unsteady and they also
induce mixing in the flow so you can
kind of imagine if you dropped some red
food coloring into this turbulent flow
it would very very rapidly start mixing
and diffusing
and kind of turn pink and then dissipate
away
so these are four of the canonical
features of turbulence that we're going
to investigate more
and i'm going to have a few videos in
this series about what is turbulence
and some examples of canonical flows how
we can analyze them things like that
i'll even do some kind of by hand
sketches and analysis in a few of these
but this is kind of the big idea we're
going to explore turbulent fluid
dynamics which
is literally all around us okay and i'll
point out
at the outset this has a tremendous
amount of value
for us as engineers when we design
aircraft and ships
and jet engines more fuel-efficient cars
and trucks and trains
absolutely you know tremendous
applications for turbulent
fluid dynamics in engineering but i
really do think that our fascination
with turbulence goes far beyond
just its usefulness and you know is
often motivated by its beauty
and by the fact that it's all around us
good okay
so when i was preparing this material i
went back to a lot of the course notes
where i learned turbulence
and i was fortunate to learn turbulence
from lex smiths
at princeton and you can download these
course notes for mae
553 viscous flows and turbulence by
by lex i highly recommend it this is
absolute gold and a lot of what i'm
going to pull from
uh in these videos was you know out of
this
this book so i highly encourage you to
check this out because this really is a
unique perspective
from one of the absolute foremost
leaders in the field
okay good so we're going to start
talking
about about turbulence and i want to
just
start off with some some videos and some
pictures just to kind of
you know get you thinking about what
were what we're talking about
uh this is one of my favorite videos uh
by colleagues
at kth in sweden and so this is going to
be a simulation of a boundary layer
and you know some of you have seen this
in my videos before
but this is a very very high fidelity
numerical simulation
of a developing boundary layer flow so
basically think of the flow over a wing
as that wing is going through the air
that's what this is trying to simulate
or maybe the flow over the top of your
car
or train and what you see here this has
all of the features right it's
three-dimensional it's unsteady it's
evolving in time
highly multi-scale look at the vast vast
range of scales that are captured by
this turbulent flow
and clearly it's mixing if you started
out as a little upstream particle
you'd be bouncing around between these
eddies and after
you know long enough you wouldn't know
uh which way
you end up okay so this is a great
kind of visualization of a turbulent
flow that we can have in our mind for
the kinds of things we might care about
and simulating and understanding and
modeling these flows is very important
again
if i'm designing an aircraft or i'm
designing a wing for an aircraft
i need to know what the drag coefficient
is going to be for that wing i need to
know what the skin friction
as i go through the air or through the
water is going to be
and i need to be able to know how that
changes as i increase the speed of the
flow
decrease the speed of the flow if i
change the curvature of the airfoil
things like that
and so it's very very hard to model
these things and this is currently an
open challenge in
engineering is finding better ways of
modeling and optimizing and controlling
these these turbulent flows so another
cool example and again i
kind of got this this idea from from lex
smith's
you know when you see a turbulent flow
you'll know it
because it's going to have this
multi-scale structure that the more you
zoom in
the more you see any piece you zoom into
you're going to see more turbulent
structure and more kind of fine details
and resolution
another cool example is this this
volcano erupting you pick
any spot and you zoom in and you're
going to see more roiling
and churning and turbulence and actually
one of the things i remember
lex saying was you can kind of tell how
high
budget a hollywood movie is based on how
many scales are in their turbulent
explosions okay so and
you know now i can't watch any action
movie without looking
for that multi-scale structure and i bet
you're not going to be able to either
okay another example i really like this
ocean
next project you can google and download
data and kind of follow what they're
doing but
you know climate the earth's climate the
ocean currents and the atmospheric
patterns
are highly turbulent they mix and
kind of transport material across the
globe and this is
hugely hugely important for us to better
understand
mixing and transport and dynamics in
those
turbulent systems as well good
now i also want to give an example one
of my favorite examples
is this rayleigh bernard convection flow
where you have a hot plate on the bottom
and a cold plate on the top
and you can see that just from this
thermal instability you get this
kind of rising of the warm air and
dropping of the cool air
and eventually you're going to see this
start to mix
in a pretty chaotic fashion now this is
not three-dimensional
so but it is unsteady multi-scale and
and mixing
and this is one of the original problems
that motivated
chaos theory so uh lorenz in 1963 was
studying this kind of rayleigh bernard
convection flow
trying to model the chaotic
churning and overturning of these large
large eddies
in this domain and so i think there's
always a
very deep connection between turbulent
fluids
and chaotic dynamical systems and that's
kind of where this
mixing idea comes from i started with
this red blob that was coherent
after a very short amount of time in
this chaotic system it's going to mix
and spread
around and that's what happens to
particles in turbulent fluids as well
okay and i'll talk a lot more about
chaos
in future in future videos so now i want
to get a little bit more into the
mathematics of kind of where this comes
from and how do we analyze these flows
and so we're going to start with the
incompressible navy or stokes equations
and i'll point out that this bold u that
i'm dealing with here is really a three
component velocity field
so u v and w are the x the y
and the z or z component of the velocity
field
and that's defined everywhere in space
and in time okay so u is a
is a vector field and these are the
governing navier-stokes equations
now from these equations you get a whole
range of interesting flow phenomena
just by speeding up or slowing down the
flow
so we have slow flows up here and fast
flows down here and you get this rich
range of dynamics as you increase the
flow velocity
i took this from the the feynman
lectures and it turns out that this
this range of complexity is controlled
by this number here called the reynolds
number so 1 over the reynolds number
and the reynolds number is essentially a
product of the fluid density
the velocity of the flow the diameter of
the
of the sphere in this case or the
cylinder divided by
this uh dynamic viscosity quantity and
so you you multiply and divide all of
this up
and this one number tells you if you're
going to have a simple flow or
a very very complex flow okay so
increasing either the diameter d
or the flow velocity will make the flow
more turbulent
okay and decreasing those makes it more
laminar or less turbulent
and this turns out to be an extremely
useful
concept that increasing the reynolds
number generally corresponds to an
increase in complexity
and turbulence and multi-scaleness
of the flow and in fact the reynolds
number can somehow be thought of
as the ratio of the biggest
scales in the flow to the teeny tiniest
scales in the flow so if i have a
reynolds number of a million
i'm going to expect eddie's uh you know
that
are a million times bigger than the
teeny tiniest eddies
or or swirls or vortices in the flow
okay that's just a kind of a rule of
thumb
but a very very useful one okay good
[Music]
you can also plot the drag coefficient
versus this increasing reynolds number
so this is a curve
i believe from nasa and you can see that
as
the flow field changes as you get this
kind of increased complexity
from the turbulence in this flow field
as you increase the reynolds number or
the flow velocity
you can see that you get a wide wide
range of drag forces
on that cylinder so you get you know
huge range of drag forces just by
changing the flow velocity
now i can't help myself i have to
relate this back to the galileo's famous
ball drop experiment from the leaning
tower of pisa
you can now picture dropping this ball
from this tower
as it accelerates uh from gravity
and speeds up it's going to transition
through all of these different flow
regimes
and experience massively different drag
forces at every
stage of its fall and so technically its
acceleration is not going to be
you know exactly a constant due to
gravity
because it's going to have this very
unsteady uh
drag force due to these turbulent forces
and it turns out you know this is
actually pretty consistent with the
older aristotelian view of uh
you know a ball's trajectory is going to
depend on its mass
or its density or its ability to resist
these unsteady
turbulent forces so just kind of an
interesting
connection if you think about that ball
drop experiment it's actually not
so obvious that gravity would be a
constant if you did it
you know naively now if you drop a heavy
enough ball like a
bowling ball maybe these are kind of
negligible forces
okay good uh so i want to go back why do
we call this the reynolds number
um so that number that reynolds number
that controlled the turbulence from
laminar
or smooth solutions laminar kind of
means layered
and so that means not roiling not
unsteady or
turbulent and it turns out that reynolds
osborne reynolds in 1883
was doing experiments in a pipe so pipe
flow is one of the most
important and oldest engineering
applications of fluids
is literally just pumping water through
pipes makes sense
you you know how big of a motor do i
need to pump all of that water through
all of my city streets
okay and to pump all of the sewage out
and so
pumping water through pipes has always
been important
and osborne reynolds was studying you
know the flow through these pipes
and made a very interesting observation
that as he increased the flow velocity
he had these very different regions or
or characteristics
of flow from laminar flow again layered
or very kind of
steady flow all the way down to these
turbulent flow scenarios where the flow
is kind of roiling
you know what you picture as turbulence
now i don't think this picture
does does this experiment justice
because in this picture he looks very
calm
and composed but you can imagine if you
were trying to do an experiment of pipe
flow and you were trying to get a smooth
solution
to collect whatever numbers you cared
about and it was getting turbulent and
roiling
you might have thought that something
was wrong with the experiment that you
weren't doing it carefully enough or
that maybe your flow wasn't well
conditioned going
in so i think in this picture he really
should have been biting his nails and
pulling his hair out but
you know this is a little bit more
composed and actually uh you can go and
see
this uh original apparatus at the
university of manchester so it's still
there
and it's still kind of on display which
i think is kind of cool
but so a long time ago we've known that
there were these transitions as you
increase the flow velocity you can trip
the flow
into these very complex disordered
turbulent solutions
okay good so
let's go back to uh kind of this picture
here
so as we increase the reynolds number we
get more and more complex turbulent
flows
but what i want to point out here is
that uh this this flow here in the
middle this kind of reynolds number 100
flow
is laminar so it's not turbulent it is
unsteady
but it's very predictable so it does the
same thing
over and over and over again it's not
kind of statistically unreliable
like these turbulent flows in the bottom
but the
the middle and the next one are actually
very similar
okay so this is the laminar flow and
this is a turbulent flow
but they have a lot of the same patterns
and structures
and so what i want to point out is that
turbulence is not random
a lot of people think that chaotic
systems or turbulent systems are random
and it's true that they have an element
of randomness or stochasticity to them
but they are not random and so in fact
there are
what are known as coherent structures or
patterns
that emerge even in these very very
complex turbulent flow fields
so this is a picture i pulled from a
review paper by sam tyra
and collaborators in 2017 i absolutely
love this figure
it shows the flow over richiri island in
japan
it's literally you know the flow over an
island this is an atmospheric flow
and then the very very simple laminar
low reynolds number flow past a cylinder
in the bottom
and you can see that even though the
reynolds number you know this one's
probably in the millions or tens or
hundreds of millions
you get the same qualitative patterns
emerging
in these flows okay and so that's really
important
is trying to understand and characterize
those big patterns in turbulent flows
now i recently saw this video on
on twitter and i absolutely love it so
this is a live
video of the atmospheric flow over
guadalupe island
and again clear as day you can see the
emergence of this carmen vortex street
forming in this flow even though it's
you know astronomically high reynolds
number extreme
complexity but these patterns these
coherent structures emerge
now this was observed early on uh by
brown and roshko in 1974
when they were looking at these mixing
layers so these are
compressible mixing layers in the
laminar low reynolds number
and turbulent high reynolds number
regime and you can see
that you know even though the turbulent
flow has a lot more complexity and kind
of multi-scale behavior
there are a lot of similarities between
the laminar and the turbulent case
given by these coherent structures so
brown was actually the other person i
learned fluids from at princeton gary
brown
really fantastic lectures uh rosh go
this is not the roscoe of um chicken and
waffles although this roscoe
also was in l.a i love this picture i
mean this really
this changed the way that everybody
thought about fluids when this picture
came out it's one of the most famous
pictures
in all of fluid mechanics because it
showed that even though you have
you know this incredible complexity it
has a lot of the same patterns of much
much simpler flows
and that really got people thinking
about these coherent structures
how to characterize them how to quantify
them how to model them and so
decades of work maybe the next you know
50 years up until now
a lot of it's been motivated by kind of
this seminal picture
very cool okay good so
coherent structures exist uh we want to
model them and characterize them
and understand them uh just a couple of
other things i want to point out
there's also something called
intermittency i pulled this again
directly from lex smith's
book and intermittency you can kind of
picture this if you have clouds that are
kind of developing on the planes
as uh you know as the the ground heats
up and the sun is up
and you have this wind and this boundary
layer forming and convecting over
earth some areas of it are going to be
more turbulent
than others and some patches you're
going to see are actually pretty still
there's going to be patches of still and
turbulent and still
and turbulent and so turbulent flows are
often
what is called intermittent and so you
can define this intermittency function
which essentially turns on and turns off
and turns on and turns off
and it tells you when it's turbulent or
not turbulent or turbulent
or not turbulent either in space or in
time
that often happens you can kind of
picture if you have a stick of incense
or a cigarette
and the smoke is rising you know
sometimes it's going to be pretty
laminar sometimes it's going to be very
turbulent
it might actually kind of settle down
again and then get more turbulent again
and this kind of intermittency is a
hallmark feature
okay so turbulent flows are everywhere
they're extremely complex they're very
important for us as engineers and
scientists
and they have all of these different
kind of complexities and features
so how do we get a handle on this
complexity how do we start to model
this now what we have done for you know
the last hundred years
since reynolds and probably before
is we've tried to abstract the turbulent
fluid dynamics problem
into a few canonical flows simple
example flows that isolate a couple of
features you know one or two features
that are that add to the complexity of
turbulence so we can really drill down
and start understanding those
constituent pieces now real engineering
flows like you know a
boeing jet flying through turbulence is
going to have a lot
of these kind of aspects you know
there's going to be a jet
there's going to be a mixing layer and a
boundary layer and isotropic turbulence
there's gonna be all of these different
pieces working together but before we
tackle those huge problems
we kind of break it down and distill it
into you know isolated
kind of idealized problems there is a
gorgeous book
by milton van dyke called an album of
fluid motion
where he walks through you know
beautiful flow visualizations of some of
these canonical flows
i think you can find pdfs online it is
really really cool you should check this
out
but here is just some of my favorite
canonical flows um
you know wall-bounded flows like the
boundary layer mixing flows so
um you know what does the flow behind a
wing look like
uh pipe flows again pumping you know
water or oil through pipes
very economically important and so on
and so forth
and so here i'm just going to go through
a couple of these and i'm going to have
a whole lecture the next lecture is
going to be all about
zooming into these canonical flows why
they're interesting what are some of the
questions we want to ask
and answer okay but this is how we've
approached fluids
uh you know essentially for the last
century and this is how we approach most
problems
in mathematical engineering where it's
too complex
is we try to abstract and boil down to
the simplest
piece that kind of exemplifies our
problem
now calling these toy problems is a
little bit uh
maybe a little too unfair these are
still quite complex and challenging
themselves
so just some example wake flows tons and
tons of effort has gone into studying
wake flows
um if you want to reduce the drag behind
a train
or a plane or a truck or a car you need
to understand the wake
behind behind that body also hugely
important for
missile design bullets and ballistics
baseballs you know lots and lots of
flows create
wakes and those wakes contribute to the
drag and unstudy forces on those bodies
another really important example are
mixing layers so again that brown and
rosco
example i showed is a mixing layer many
of you have seen these wave makers
where you have kind of oil and water in
a rectangle rotating and it creates
these waves
and these mixing layers are really
important canonical flows to understand
things like ocean waves
the flow behind a sharp trailing edge on
a wing often creates a mixing layer
and these are very very important
another very important application of
fluid dynamics and another canonical
flow
is a jet and so there are supersonic
jets you can actually see the acoustic
radiation in this turbulent supersonic
jet uh here you can actually see
kind of the mock lines forming in this
jet
and jets are extremely important for
you know producing thrust and power
also we want to minimize the noise given
high thrust and high power so you know
any of you who live near
lax or heathrow no i mean there's
there's 10 million people
in the top two or three airports alone
near the top two or three airports in
the world alone
that are directly impacted by jet noise
and decreasing that jet noise would
improve the quality of life for tens of
millions of people directly
okay so huge huge problem here okay so
canonical flows are
very important it's one of the ways that
we study
study fluid dynamics we try to break it
down so
uh here again are just some of the
canonical flows wakes and jets and
mixing layers
and we use those canonical flows to
study
much more complex engineering systems
like trains and boats and planes and
engines and things like that
okay so many of these flows are going to
have lots of
elements of these canonical flows and
i'll talk about that later
so for example you know a wind turbine
blade there's going to be boundary
layers and mixing
layers and wake flows all of those
interacting
in a pretty complex system and at the
end of the day we want to understand
these systems we want to be able to
model them and understand what they will
do
when we change different things about
our engineering designs
that gives us the ability to optimize
for example design
better blades for turbines but also to
control the system to actively
manipulate the behavior of the fluid
for better engineering outcomes to
increase lift
decrease drag enhance mixing things like
that
okay and this is something i'm very
passionate about and one of the reasons
i love
turbulence as you know an important
field of fluid mechanics
okay good um so i think one of the last
things i want to point out here
is again uh we go back to this we're
always going to go back to the the navy
or stokes equations that's kind of our
entry point as
a mathematical engineers and we know
that we have this kind of increasing
complexity with the reynolds number
so one of the the kind of important
things that you can do
to study these flows and i'm going to
have a whole series of lectures on this
this is going to be the basis of what's
known as turbulence closure modeling
which is one of our approaches for
modeling these systems more efficiently
on computers
one of the things you do if we zoom into
a turbulent case
is something called the reynolds
decomposition so we're going to take
this flow field u
which is you know very complicated
function of space and time
and what we're going to do is we're
going to break it apart into an average
field u
bar and all of the fluctuating
components u prime
and so u bar we get by literally taking
this flow
u and just averaging in time we just
take flow snapshot
think of a movie of this flow evolving
i'm just going to average
all of those frames of the movie in time
and get the average frame that's the
mean flow
and then the turbulent fluctuations are
just my original flow
minus the mean flow okay and so what
we're doing is we're taking our flow and
we're decomposing it into a function
that is the average flow which is no
longer a function of time
it's just a function of space and then
all these little fluctuations all of the
turbulent fluctuations
and when i take this flow this
decomposition and plug it into the
navier-stokes equations i get lots of
interesting things
happening i get an equation i a
navier-stokes equation
for the mean flow and for the
fluctuating components and i can model
things more efficiently this way
okay so huge field of reynolds averaging
but this is a very useful perspective
where we decompose our flow into the
average flow and the fluctuations
and i'll point out this is a largely
historical why we do this and it's kind
of fortuitous
is that historically we didn't have
computers to measure these flow fields
accurately in space and time
we didn't have laser technology until
the 60s
50s and 60s so that we could build laser
sheets to image
the full flow field and experiments and
so back in the olden days
you were stuck with single point
measurements hot wires
where you would put a hot wire in the
flow and i could maybe measure that
for a long time and figure out what its
statistics were and average
and build the fluctuations and then i
could move it one delta x
or delta y down and then i could move it
again and move it again
and in the course of a day or a few days
i might be able to measure the entire
wake
point by point in a time series fashion
but i can't tell what every point is
doing at the same time
and so this idea of averaging your flow
is actually you know
goes back to the days when we didn't
have enhanced measurement techniques
and computers but it turns out that it's
a very very useful perspective for
modeling today
so that's pretty cool okay good so i'm
going to have a whole lecture on
reynolds averaging
soon this is going to be kind of a pen
and paper or like lightboard
video lecture and i hope that i have
convinced you in this lecture that
turbulence is interesting
it's everywhere it's extremely important
and it has these kind of four
canonical attributes that's how these
these are like the fingerprint of
turbulence when you see
three-dimensional multi-scale unsteady
mixing flows
you know it's turbulence okay
stay tuned there's going to be a lot
more to come thank you